-Guys, finally it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Now, welcome to "WePost."
This is where we
as a group decide something
that we should post on socials.
I'm going to show you
five different posts,
and we're all going to vote
on whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Do you see them there?
I see some people
there getting them.
Okay, good.
You can vote for all of these.
By the way, I should remind you.
Or you can vote for none.
You can have whatever
you want to do.
I want you to have a good time.
Higgins, Roots,
you all have your clickers?
-Got it.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright. I'm going to post
whichever one
gets the most likes
from all of us,
because it's not a me post.
It's a "we" post.
-Oh, nice.
-Yeah. Thanks.
Maybe like get some beat
or a drum or.
[ Hi-hat note plays ]
No, no.
Like a -- like a --
[ Bass note plays ]
Yeah. That's more like it.
-Thank you.
-That's right.
It's a --
It's a "we" post.
[ Bass beat plays ]
Alright.
You guys ready.
The first post is...
[ Laughter ]
Who's doing this stuff.
Like, yeah, [Nasally voice]
"You're going to love this.
You won't believe
how off road this..."
[ Normal voice ]
Where do you live?
Pave your driveway, dude.
Yeah. Alright, let's see.
Here we go. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Ooh.
-Alright.
Mediocre. Mediocre.
You know what I feel?
I feel like maybe
the audience is lit too hot.
Maybe they're afraid
to do their real votes.
They like be --
-They don't
want people to know.
The darker in the audience,
they'll be more --
It's almost like
people online, they go,
"Oh, I didn't like that."
-Right.
-If you couldn't see their face,
Be like, "Oh, it's pretty good."
-Yeah.
-Maybe we dim the audience,
we dim the lights.
Can we do that?
Can we bring down the lights?
Yeah. Taking their time.
-Oh, there we go.
-Oh, wow.
Woo! Yeah.
Now, now things are going
to get real.
-Things are going
to get weird.
-Things are going to get --
No not weird.
-Oh, okay.
-Things will get real.
Nothing's going to get weird.
Alright here we go.
This next one is...
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
There you go.
It's like...
-Eh, 190, 80, 70, 60.
-What do you want me to say?
Yeah. Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see the results here.
-Oh.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I felt like everyone
can be more honest.
-171, yeah.
-Yes. We're being more honest
with each other
and I appreciate that.
It's probably --
You think it's going
to be the winner.
-Uh, no, no, no, no.
-You don't think so?
-It's absolutely not
going to be the winner.
-That is --
I think that's the winner.
I think whatever is next,
this next one is going to be
the winner no matter what.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
I'm willing it to be.
Me -- Me --
-You're manifesting.
-Me and all my pals, yeah,
we're going to manifest it.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's manifest destiny, bro.
-You want to see what it is?
-No, we don't need
to know what it is.
Just let her rip
and let's get to thumbs upping.
[ Laughter ]
-The thumbs upping?
-Yeah, man.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's the next one.
Alright.
-Done.
We're ready, we're done.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
-I like it. I like it.
-It's getting --
It's already getting recycled
as you're -- as you're sipping,
it's already disintegrating
into the beverage.
-Now, it's cardboard 2.
-Yeah. Exactly.
Alright.
Let's see the results here.
[ Drum roll ]
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Wow.
[ Music ends ]
That went up a dozen.
-There's no way that's better
than the scale one.
-Yeah, yeah it is.
-The scale one was great.
-This one was
a shared experience.
-Next up, it says...
[ Audience groans ]
-This is like.
-Whoop!
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
-Tariq's thumbs downing it.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
Let's see
the results on this one.
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
Wow.
-Maybe --
Maybe we turn
the lights back on.
Turn the lights back up
in the audience.
That's what I'm --
Oh, I can see everybody now.
Now, people can feel guilty
if they're voting down.
Now I can look at them all.
Come on, guys,
this is for programing here.
This is for --
-This is for TV.
-This is for television.
A lot of people watching,
making sure that we get
the best quality posts.
-Yeah.
-That scale one was quality.
-Yeah. You're saying
Tariq rigged the game?
-No, I'm just saying that paper
one was good.
-But not "good."
-How did that scale one --
-It wasn't scale good, huh?
-Take the power back.
Will this one into,
you know.
-Oh, you want me...
-...how is it.
-...to take the power
and make this one the best.
-Yes.
-Oh!
-Well, it's not
going to happen.
[ Laughter ]
-You've read it.
-I can see this one.
This one's good.
-It's good,
but it's not paper straw good.
-Mm.
-Paper straw was good.
But I don't think
that's as good as scale good.
-Right.
-Can we redo scale?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, Jimmy.
What's done is done.
Are you kidding me?
Redo, are you kidding me?
-No one's saying
you can't do it.
[ As Trump ]
I think it's rigged.
I think Tariq --
I bet it's all rigged.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
I just need a couple more votes.
[ Laughter ]
I just need
a couple more votes
to make sure,
make it real.
-Come on, let's go,
let's go, let's go.
I ain't got all day.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, guys,
alright, here we go.
The last one here says...
-Get out!
Yes!
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Haha, yeah!
Come on.
Are you feeling it?
-I'm winning a billion times.
-Yes.
-You feeling it?!
[ Music stops ]
-Okay. Let's see the results!
[ Drum roll ]
-Oh!
-Number one!
-One away!
[ Laughter ]
-One away.
Which one of you...?
[ Laughs ]
-By one vote.
-Who thumbs downed that?
And that was you right there.
The thumbs down. There you go.
Alright.
The winner is right there.
I'm going to post it during
the commercial break.
If you happen to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.
Thank you for playing.